I think the answer right now to
everything is more yeah you know
everyone's like what should I do for my
personal branding like as much as
possible
if you can do a daily podcast yes if you
can do a vlog yes if you can post five
times a day on Instagram yes if you can
do 30 posts for stories for Instagram
and snapchat yes if you can reply to 50
people on Twitter yeah like to me the
answer is yes and so what the blog does
so for example the posts that I
personally just posted on Instagram is
I'll show you exactly how it works
you'll find it interesting so this post
that I just posted is something I said
to a question right the way it actually
works is soon as I get so many texts
it's got slow I gotta figure it out
so my team is on here right so here's
how it works I'll get a text like this
from somebody on the team for them
things I've said yeah right so I said
this in dailyvee for 55 read it right
and then I'll reply with only the ones I
like two and four and then you know
hours later or first thing tomorrow I'll
get that yeah got it yeah
this is what I was like asking mm-hmm I
want to know how I think I think the I
think the right number for somebody
who's like really going for it
is six what do you think you're right
Yeah right I mean if we really if we
really weren't building it for Vayner
talent for vaynermedia if we were just
me we'd probably be six right one paid
one video one writer one audio what one
designer it'd be tight six only six is
crazy yeah like I don't know anybody who
has six for one person yeah I mean it
was it was just me for seven years you
know yes he's not that's gonna help a
lot what the vlog did was opened up
everything else it opened up everything
else now I don't I document I don't
create right so even this clip even this
is very meta because now it might be
titled for Facebook like how somebody
should be thinking about building out
their team friend here it is I didn't
have to sit and write you know what I
mean or I don't have a writer right now
he moved on to another opportunity but
if but I'm not hiring one and now this
could be a LinkedIn post and she or he
can listen to this whole thing write it
in first person then they'll call me and
ask me two or three more questions I'll
answer and now you got an article
because I think they all matter
audio-video pictures I totally get it
I told